over 100 acting credits 30 years how are
you not only enduring not not just
hanging on but thriving how is that
happening I think I like it more now
than I did earlier I think I like it a
lot more now you know IIIi just have
such regard for our colleagues it's a
joy to show up on set and get to play
you know we get to play for a living we
get to pretend and anything that stops
you from playing is not good get rid of
it you know some specific technique or
I've got to do it this way if it stops
you get rid of it it's not helping do
you want something that let you play and
I found myself I was never very good at
playing as a child and I certainly
wasn't very good at playing as a young
actor and I've gotten younger as I've
gotten older so it's allowed me you know
to my favorite quote is George Bernard
Shaw said every stroke of genius is a
lucky miss reckoning so I love the happy
accidents and they can happen if you
play so I just like going in in the
morning and and seeing who I get to play
with on that given day and hope for a
little variety
you know I'm serviceable is some sort of
a law enforcement or a problem solver or
something like that but every now and
again something will come along that'll
really rattle my cage and that that
keeps you going you know I've had a
couple of opportunities here lately with
Dallas buyers club and Bates Motel and
you know the play people that were a
little bit different
certainly the character I did in bass
motel is a very dangerous man charming
but dangerous and then I got to you know
turn around and play in LA he's a career
criminal and in Bates Motel
and then I got to turn around a month
later and play the lead LAPD detective
that was chasing the longest operating
serial killer in the history of
California and so I mean
we get to wear different hats I would be
a disaster in life if I didn't get to
change hats
I really would I I don't have the focus
or the you know my emotional IQ is
pretty high I don't know what my you
know my my intelligence IQ is so if I
had to if that's what I had to apply I
have great respect for those people I
don't know how they do it but it's not
Michael O'Neill you know so I just got
lucky to be doing this do you think that
over time there comes and I want to say
this and the right way and it's not
really you don't take things too
seriously maybe not that you know you
show up prepared you have the lines down
you're there early before most people
are there but maybe the competitive part
or there's just there's something where
you let go and you question okay why am
I doing this and then you're able to do
it for you yeah you know and that may go
back to that the big dream in the little
dream the big one having to die what you
think it's supposed to look like as
opposed to what it does look like
you know and I do think I do think you
season into it you season into a
relaxation that's what I work on all the
time you I'm trying to relax I'm trying
to relax and I'm trying to maintain
concentration it's harder to learn lines
and so I I want to make sure that that's
not what I'm thinking about the whole
times oh my god what's my next line I
don't listen to him I gotta figure out
my next line is so there there is some
of that you know you you just got to
relax with it more look I mean I've
never seen any job coming I mean that's
the other remarkable aspect of what we
do you can't see it coming I didn't know
I'd still don't know I don't know what
my next job is sadly I don't know that
there'll be a next job what I do know is
that my job is to show up that's the
actor's job I mean you show up prepared
you show up and try to do the best you
can but you got to show up and it's
funny I kind of learned that watching
that audition that I was talking about
to see those actors come in and not want
the job they were there but they didn't
show up and I take nothing away from
them I don't mean to be critical of him
about that because I've done the same
thing I've been on auditions where I
didn't show up I didn't really want that
I was afraid of that
and I think the proudest moments I've
had when I was really afraid and I did
it anyway
you know I don't think there's much
courage without fear and it's a fearful
thing to go in and have to be evaluated
all the time you know it's not like
they're evaluating my jacket it's me
it's I'm the I'm the quote-unquote
product and if they reject it's me and
so it helped me to have a family it
really helped me to have a family
because my kids when I came home you
know when I hit the front door dad's all
we can you spin us around can you do
that thing you do you know and and they
didn't care whether the audition had
gone well or not if the job had gone
well or not that that that probably
saved me
at a critical time in my quote/unquote
career
you